the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay let's get started can we get them
up so this is our thing spinning what
are the units of generalized force in
this problem which is going to be
related to the torque at the bottom so
most people said Newton meters which is
the units of torque and that would be
correct so this is you're going to get
some I beta double dot kind of equation
of motion with this has units of moment
or torque and any external
non-conservative force on it would in
this case have units of torque
okay next so we have a pendulum kind of
an odd shape that is does it have
symmetries name asymmetry that this
thing has and I mean axial then or a
plane or a y-axis or a plane okay so
this is this thing has symmetries it's
pretty you could convince yourself
pretty quickly that the principal axes
would one be right down the center of it
and the other two would be perpendicular
to that so is it as it appropriate to
use the parallel axis theorem to find an
equation of motion of this thing for
when it's pinned at the top and most
people said yes if you said no I think
parallel axis theorem works just great
in this problem it's planar motion and
the for example the kinetic energy you
could write as the as one-half I about
Oh up there the hinge point I with
respect to that point theta double dot
and to do I about that point you'd use
the parallel axis theorem so I about G
plus the distance L squared times M okay
this one you expect a centripetal
acceleration term to show up in your
equations of motion and some said yes
some said no so the equation of motion
for this I would probably write in terms
of some rotation theta of the big disk
that will cause the mass on the string
to move up and down but is there any for
the part for the rotating parts of the
system are there I think of a clear way
to word this let's ignore the little
mass going up and down for a moment the
axis of rotation of that double disc and
hub and the bigger disc does the axis of
rotation go through the center of mass
of that disk
okay is it statically balanced
we haven't talked about balance in a
while good review question for thinking
about that quiz next Tuesday isn't so
what does it take what does it take for
a something which is rotating to be
considered statically balanced the axis
of rotation must what he says passed
through the center of mass anybody else
have a suggestion different suggestion
if the axis of rotation passes through
the center of mass is it statically
balanced does it have to be a principal
axis what do you think does it need is
that access passing through G have to be
a principal axis in order for it to be
statically balanced see I don't have a
little one else to be
so might this this is just a wheel and
that this my axle going through the
center of mass and if it goes through
the center of mass and there's there are
no it'll have no tendency to swing down
to a low point because the weight its
weight is acting right on its center of
mass and with respect to this axle
there's no moment arm so there's no
torque caused by gravity which could
cause us to have put its center of mass
below the axle so it doesn't matter if
even if I had the axis axis going
through here as long as that axis passes
through G there is no tendency for this
thing to swing to a low side because the
mass mg is acting right on the axle no
moment on so all yet the only condition
for static balance for a rotor of any
kind something rotating to be statically
balanced is for the axis of rotation to
pass through the mass Center okay so the
rotating part of this system the axis of
rotation passes through the mass center
of that big disc right does the little
mass M rotate so it's it can't be
statically or dynamically imbalance it's
not a rotating system it's just a little
translating mass that happens to be
being pulled up and down by the most
action of this thing so the question was
do you expect a centripetal acceleration
term to show up the answer is no so
let's get back to that if you have a
static imbalance let's say my axis of
rotation is here this is definitely
statically imbalanced now it's mass
centers down here the force of gravity
pulls it down until it hang straight
right and that's how you can just test
to see if you're passing through the
mass center so if you have an
axis that does not pass through G then
your statically imbalanced and if you
rotate about that axis is there a net
centripetal force required as it goes
around Y so the center of mass is some
distance away and you're swinging it
around and around and make that center
of mass go in a circle you're going to
at you're applying a centripetal
acceleration to the center of mass and
that takes a force which you sometimes
think of as a centrifugal force pulling
out that's what you're going to have to
pull in right some M R Omega squared
okay so no centripetal term would be
expected in this problem let's go to the
next one this one you had two different
conditions either rolling without
slipping with slip and the question is
for which conditions are the generalized
forces associated with a virtual
displacement of Delta Theta the rotation
of the wheel equal to zero
so remember generalized forces are the
forces that are account for the non
conservative forces in the problem so if
it's rolling down the hill without slip
are there any non conservative forces
acting on it is there a friction force
acting on it yeah but does it do any
work no because there's no Delta R at
the point of application of the force
there's no motion okay so for which
conditions of the generalized forces is
equal to zero certainly for the
condition when it does not slip what
about if it does slip would you expect a
non conservative force to do work on it
what would what force would that be the
friction force because now as the wheel
turns that point of application or it's
sliding you're actually getting in a
little Delta Omega Delta Theta rather
you move a little distance R Delta Theta
dotted with the force you get a little
bit of virtual work done right our delta
theta times f okay so the only case a is
where you'd get 0 oh this one what's the
generalized force associated with F
that's this applied force it's applied
to the rolling thing going down the hill
the force is horizontal and you're asked
what's the generalized force associated
with F due to the virtual displacement
Delta X and X is the motion of the main
cart so when you're doing generalized
forces you think in terms of virtual
work and you imagine that that carts
moving a little distance Delta X the
main the X in the X y ou system it
shifts a little little distance Delta X
that force does it move is the point of
application of that force move with that
Delta X that's really what the question
comes down to
this one so this is your inertial system
and it's going to account for the motion
of this object and then up here got your
wheel and we have some coordinate system
attached to this object noting the
position of the wheel as it goes up and
down the hill
so this coordinates relative to the
moving cart this coordinates an inertial
the question is only asking then what is
the virtual work done it's associated
with Delta X here some motion of the
cart and it's going to be what we're
looking for bqx Delta X and when we say
ok and the point of application of the
force is literally a F here and it's in
the horizontal direction which is
exactly the same direction as capital X
so this is equal to the force and in the
problem that's called this is just
called F it's a vector and we're trying
to deduce the deflection at the point of
application I'm going to call it summit
there can be many forces so I'm going to
call it f sub I so that we think think
of it as one of many times the
displacement Delta R I
due to Delta X so this is a vector this
is a displacement this is a force the
amount of work done as this force moves
through that displacement is some F dot
Delta R the movement at this point I
where it's applied due to this motion so
what is the Delta R at this point due to
that motion so another concept here when
you're doing this you do you think of
these mentally one at a time how many
degrees of freedom do we have in this
problem takes two to completely describe
the motion X and May and this one
attached to the cart right okay and you
think of these one at a time so right
now we're asking what's the virtual work
done by that force due to movement in
bit of this coordinate only assuming
this one is frozen so this one is not
allowed to move so if this is not a lot
moved as a position of this change
relative to this cart as you move the
cart no okay that one is held fixed it
moves with the cart so if you move the
cart a little distance here Delta X in
this frame then this wheel moves with
the cart that distance so how much work
gets done so this Delta R I in this case
is equal to Delta X and the amount of
work that gets done is
Delta W do two at point I do two Delta X
here is f dot Delta X but F is in this
is in the capital I Direction this is in
the capital eiection so it's just F
Delta X is the work done and that's Q X
Delta X so the generalized force is just
F okay
alright now what else yeah mm okay wait
a minute
all this is due the dashpot
what is generalized force associated the
dashpot due to the way virtual
deflection x1 x1 is the coordinate that
thing rolling up and down the hill so
now the same thing the dashpot force
here's your card
here's your dashpot
and a free body diagram of the cart
would show a dashpot force here B X dot
in that direction and if we move the
cart again a little bit Delta X how much
work gets done is this that's this is
not the question asked up there so just
first this how much virtual work gets
done by that in a deflection Delta X
well it's some F I dot Delta R due to
Delta X which is just Delta X so this is
some minus BX dot in the I Direction
times Delta X and the I again it's just
in this case it's - so this virtual work
done this time due to just a dashpot I'm
going to write that I don't have a sub
so this dashpot only here BX dot is B X
dot - in the I direction that's the
force dotted with the d R that it moves
and the dr that it moves is just Delta X
so this would be minus B X I dot Delta X
I is your virtual work that's done and
this is equal to Q X Delta X but this
part of this this is a part of Q X due
only to the dashpot and you get minus B
X dot Delta X so now we've gotten both
parts of the the total virtual total
generalized force associated with the
motion Delta X is
F minus BX dot general this expression Q
X Delta X is the summation over all of
the applied forces I dot Delta R at I
due to the this case the motion in the X
direction and we have two contributions
here they come from the applied force F
and this so QX in this problem is going
to turn out to be F minus B X dot okay
now what about the other what really
asking this problem is how much what's
the generalized force associated with
the motion of the wheel down the hill
this is in the x1 direction so now you
have a little deflection Delta x1 how
much virtual work gets done by the
dashpot I hear zero so a little virtual
displacement no Delta x1 does it move
the main cart that's really the what's
going on here is the main cart move
because the wheel and the main cart
change relative position a little bit no
here no here I mean that's the the
coordinate x1 is the relative motion
between their cart and the wheel and
it's independent of the motion of the
cart with respect to the inertial frame
so any motion of little wheel does not
affect the main cart okay so there's no
virtual work done by that - pod because
the wheel moves up and down the hill
and it makes sense physical sense right
the wheel gets it and roll them down
that hill all day long it's not going to
move that dashpot okay next this problem
I just realized this problems harder
than I thought it was it's one of those
things that you know you look at it oh
that looks straightforward then I looked
at doddery solution and said oh she did
it right and this little trickier then
you might think so are the a XYZ axes
which rotate with the hub so there's a
rotating they are definitely principal
coordinates of that rod that's not a
problem but are they principal
coordinates for the at disc out on the
end pardon
depends if it's actually no I don't
think so
the principal is talk of what our
principal coordinates need to be
attached to the body right so problems
like this - let's say we're using
Lagrange and we want to calculate the
total kinetic you need to calculate the
total kinetic energy of the system so
how would you how would you go about
breaking this thing down to compute the
total kinetic energy would you break it
into more than one part would it be the
natural things to break it into the disk
in the rod right so the kinetic energy
of the rod that's pretty straightforward
it's some one-half I with respect to the
center theta dot squared Omega squared
but the kinetic energy of that disc out
there you need to account for its
rotation and its movement of its center
of mass in the circle
so let's I'm winging it now so
bear with me if I make any mistakes you
can help me out
T rod would be in our coordinate system
is an a should at the center you're
actually isn't it the o nsz a so T the
rod I would argue is one-half M of the
rod Omega
squared M l squared over 3 because it's
rotating about one end so the applied
the parallel axis theorem the kinetic
energy of the rod is one-half M I with
respect to that central axis they make a
squared and so that gets you this that
gets you from ml squared over 12 to ml
squared over 3 because you're swinging
around one end but now we need T of the
disc and the duty of the disc I would do
it by saying 1/2 m of the disc velocity
of the center of mass of the disc in O
dot VJ oh so that takes care of its
kinetic energy due to motion of its
center of mass plus 1/2 Omega dot H with
respect to G with respect to G you can
you express H for the disc in terms of a
mass moment of inertia and some
rotations rotation rates is it
legitimate
and where I started a few days ago I
started the top and said here's the
general expression for kinetic energy
all full 3d right and it basically was
that expression that works full 3d and
then when you fix the memory when you
fix a point about which something is
rotating a rigid body then you can
simplify it but in this case H you could
represent the angular momentum with
around G as some I Omega and then you
have to multiply it by so this inside of
here will be you can represent this in
here as sum I Omega dotted with Omega
and you will get the kinetic energy due
to the rotation of the disk what makes
this problem a little trickier than I
thought I wasn't thinking really clearly
is that Omega is in what frame do you
express Omega in when you're doing
computing H with in terms of mass
moments of inertia in order to compute I
you have to use what coordinate system
body fixed and when you compute I Omega
what's the omeg what unit vectors is the
Omega expressed in but in what so the
unit vectors associated with what
coordinate system are the ones that you
use to define Omega the one attached to
the body or not generally in terms of
the one attached to the body and this
the disk gets that means they're
rotating gets a little messy so I'm not
going to do it because I can't do it in
my head so this one you you need to do
the kinetic energy of that you need to
use this approach and have to be careful
with those food-for-thought at office
hours and
recitation okay all right
I had meant to start to start today
we're half we're but well in and I
haven't even started where I was going
to really go today
so I have kind of a broken play up just
like with the drop give me a moment
so the principal thing I want to talk
about today was to dig a little deeper
into finding generalized forces and well
the way we've been doing it is what I
would call kind of an intuitive approach
let's imagine we've got a rigid body and
I have some forces acting on it f1
and at the point of application of each
of these forces I have a physician
vector that goes there so there's R 1 R
2 R 3 and they're all with respect to my
Oh frame here but I'm going to not write
in all the O's let's let's say that this
is a body in planar motion so it's kind
of fine to a plane it's a rigid body
it's like my disc there so how many
degrees of freedom at most would it have
if there's no constraints three right
can move in the X and the y and it can
rotate in the Z so potentially three
degrees of freedom so it'll take let's
say gee is he maybe here so we need
three generalized coordinates and they
would be say X Y and some rotation of
theta and with them we have virtual
displacements Delta X Delta Y and Delta
Theta and we use those to figure out the
amount of non conservative work that
happens when you make those little small
motions occur and we're trying to find
we need to find QX qy and Q theta the
generalized forces associated with these
small variations virtual deflections in
our three coordinates
so the j1 you know a bunch of forces may
be after here someone here that's some
FJ so the generalized force I don't mean
that that's the F either F is the J is
refer to our generalized coordinates so
generalized force QJ Delta QJ
this is the little bit of work done in
the virtual deflection Delta QJ and it
there's work done by all of these
applied forces in the system possibly
every one if I cause there are a little
little Delta X of this body it moves
over an amount Delta X all of those
points of application of those forces
move a little bit and therefore at every
location a little bit of work gets done
so in order to account for all of the
work I have to do a summation of the FI
dot Delta R at I and now this is
associated with the virtual displacement
of generalized coordinate J so the total
virtual work done by a displacement of
one of these is a summation of all the
little bits of work done at all the
applicant points of application of
forces dotted with the amount that it
the point of application of that force
moves caused by Delta QJ so in general
that's what the total QJ would be now
we've done problems like that more or
less kind of intuitively we figured it
out and said ok if it moves as much then
it's going to move over that much and if
there is an angle between them we take
the component and we just figure it out
is there a more mathematical way of
doing this and so I'm going to show you
that so we've been doing this kind of
the intuitive approach here
their reasoning out each of the
deflections and calculating the result
that there's a kinematic there's an
explicit kinematic way of doing this
yeah yeah okay I'm sorry it says this is
a delta r i have double subscripts here
this is the displacement at the point of
application of force I do to the virtual
displacement of generalized coordinate J
so that an example might be if that's
Delta X over here the summation is over
over over I is over F 1 F 2 to F I and
the deflection is the deflection at the
point of application I do to in this
case I'm talking about Delta X due to
the virtual displacement Delta X okay
and so that's you we'd work each one of
these out and add them up and we'd have
the answer but is there is a more kind
of explicit mathematical way of saying
this and that is to say that Q J Delta Q
J is the summation over I equals 1 to N
however many there are of F I dot the
derivative of R i with respect to Q J
Delta Q J what's that mean so let's
let's look at one of these so force one
there's a position vector R 1 if I move
in the x-direction a little Delta X this
point moves over Delta X in that
direction and in the X direction
horizontally our position vector r1 has
potentially components in the Y as well
as components in the X but I'm only
changing it in the X direction so that
portion of the possible movement of r1
due to changes in just one of the
coordinates in this case I was doing Q X
the derivative of r1 with respect to Q X
so only a part of its total possible
movement is due to X this gives us that
portion times Delta Q X is the total
movement in the direction of Q X dotted
with the force you get the work done so
I find this if I were you this is highly
abstract let's I think we need to do an
example of this and see how it works out
and since we were talking about that
problem I'll do this cart by this method
so I need a position vector to the point
of application of this external
non-conservative force because I'm
calling this force one I'll call that
position vector r1 and it goes from here
to there and but we know that the total
motion at this point is made up of the
motion of the main cart plus the motion
of the wheel relative to the main cart
and so we fall back on our notation so
I'll say this is our 1 & 0 here's my
point a it's our vector this is our of a
with respect to O plus and we'll better
give this a name what if I so this is my
point 1 here so this is plus r1 with
respect to a so we've done that lots of
times this term that's just how that
point is the sum of this vector Plus
that Plus this vector so you have an R
this is r1 with respect to a from here
to here and the sum of those two is this
one so this is r1 here okay and so let's
see if we can write come up with an
expression for that well this point a is
just X in the I plus some Y in the J
that's this term then I need this one
so I want because I'm going to have to
take some derivatives and things I need
to get every I want to get everything in
terms of want unit vectors in one system
so I know this one this is my x1 and it
will have a unit vector I lowercase I in
this direction so the unit vector I here
has components in the capital IJ system
and this is theta that's theta so in
this has AI has a component here which
is cosine theta cap I and then this
piece is minus sine theta J so this
should be
x1 the distance this thing moves broken
into two pieces cos theta I minus sine
theta J so that's now the position of
this thing is the position of the cart
at a plus the vector that goes from a to
the two point one which is the distance
X 1/2 here broken into two pieces and
eyepiece and JP's so now we're almost
done so I would like to find Q X and Q X
then should be the summation well let's
see
so I'm only going to compute the part of
the generalized force in the QX
Direction due to just this one force now
we have other fort member we have other
forces non conservative forces acting on
this we got to be X dot too but I'm just
going to do the contribution to QX that
comes from this force f1 and it'll show
a QX Delta X is the virtual work done is
f1 i dot partial of R 1 with respect to
X Delta X but the derivative of r1 with
respect to capital X there's no capital
X's over here so there's nothing comes
from that there's one right here so the
derivative of X with respect to X gives
me 1 I just get 1 times I back here f1 I
hat dot I hat Delta X so it's just f1
Delta X which we knew intuitively when
we work this problem earlier when we
were talking about it the amount of work
virtual work that gets done by this
particular force in a deflection this
virtual displacement Delta X just f1
Delta X but we've proven it we've done
it in a very in a precise kinematic way
where we found a position vector work
the whole thing out so that's the simple
one let's now find
the harder one but not much now we'd
like to find qx1 due to just this f1
only delta x1 well that should be f1 i
dot partial of R 1 with respect to X 1
Delta X 1 so the derivative of R 1 with
respect to X 1 X this is not this stuff
has nothing to do with X 1 the X 1 only
appears over here and the derivative of
this expression just cosine I minus sine
a 2 J
so I dot I is the only part you get back
this is and I need a delta x1 f1 I dot I
is cosine theta Delta x1 so Q x1 + f1
only here equals f1 cosine theta so this
time the motion Delta x1 only part of it
is in the direction of f1 and that
portion by taking this derivative here
we get the contribution to this that
comes from x1 and then dotted with the
force we only take that component of
that motion in the direction of the
force and that gives us our total
virtual work so here is that the total
virtual work done by f1 due to the
little motion Delta x1 so we've now
we've got the contribution here to the
generalized force dude that is
associated with deflections of
coordinate x1 are there any other is
that the total generalized force for
associated with generalized coordinate
x1 in this problem are there any other
non conservative forces in the problem
that move when Delta x1 is moved well
let's see
friction if you if we have friction
you're presuming on the wheel ok so he
asks about friction on the wheel well
let's say that there's no slip in this
case
then does the friction at the point of
contact with the wheel do any work
no so do we have to account for it as a
generalized force no okay so how about
the dashpot so a little virtual
deflection Delta x1 does it make the big
cart move no so is there any are there
any other forces in the problem that
move when you cause a small movement in
x1 so this is the total in this case
this is the total QX one up here we
found QX the generalized force due to
the motion of the cart the contribution
by f1 but is there another contribution
and it is the dashpot so we get
additionally the total QX here total
would be the summation of two pieces an
f1 and an f2 which I'd call minus BX
it's in the same direction as Delta X so
it's you're going to get a minus BX dot
plus f1 would be the total generalized
force in the capital X direction the
movement of the main cart okay
so anytime you can actually figure out
it you can actually specify a position
vector to the point of application of an
external non-conservative force then you
can just plug it into this you do it at
each force that's applied it take the
derivative with respect to that to
coordinate Q J Delta Q J that is the
virtual work done I force each of these
forces and you add up to get the total
virtual work done due to a deflection at
that particular coordinate J so in the
case of capital of Q X we had two
contributions because we had two forces
on the main cart f1 and minus BX dot and
so the summation in that in that problem
when this is capital X cube Delta X you
have two contributions f1 and f2 okay
now what else is what else can I do in
the length of time actually I felt me
stop for a moment there think about this
and what do you have any questions about
this so we've described two ways as
getting generalized forces once kind of
the intuitive one figure out how much it
moves into direction and do the dot
product the other one is a straight
mathematical way kinematics plug it in
take the derivative same thing will come
out so you're thinking about a question
I'll look and think what I was going to
do next okay
so I know what I'll do next but do you
have any questions on this I'm going to
do another example of this ah Christina
yeah
is the wheel it's all in how you specify
your generalized coordinates so in this
problem the two generalized coordinates
are is capital X in the inertial system
which describes the motion of the cart
and little and X 1 describes the motion
of the wheel relative to the cart and
that's actually that allows you to write
this statement this is this is only
relative to the cart right so the motion
of the cart plus the motion of the point
relative to the cart gives you the total
motion and you've picked two coordinates
that allow you to describe those two
things so if you can in this problem if
this is the cart
this is the wheel and I even have a
spring hook to it here if I move this a
little bit the cart doesn't have to move
like this just going back and forth
accounts for x1 relative to this table
and the table is the curve
you mean be dynamically because you're
putting forces on it yeah well we might
but that's not is the in a way you're
asking the question is the cart capable
of moving because you put a force in the
wheel you move the wheel which puts more
spring force which may be that causes
the cart to move yeah that could happen
but that's not what you that's not the
problem you're solving when you're
trying to find the generalized forces
you're in fact allowing a single motion
at a time so if you're talking about
this motion you have frozen the motion
of the main cart and you figure out what
the consequence of that is it does a
little virtual work because there's a
force and you get one of the generalized
forces then if you move the card you fix
the wheel and the whole cart moves but
there's the end the amount that this
wheel moves is exactly equal to the
amount that the cart moves because
you've now fixed this relative position
and that's where you get the first
that's where you get the capital Q X
term even though the force f1 is applied
here on the wheel this wheel moves when
the table moves but the table doesn't
move when this relative coordinate
between the table and here changes it
doesn't have to it's this is free to
move when the table is frozen remember
we talked about complete and independent
coordinates x1 is independent of capital
X if I freeze x1 and I make capital X
change just the whole thing moves like
that if I freeze capital X x1 can still
move so that that's the so you have to
you have to pick independent coordinates
yeah
okay that's a good question it's similar
that's essentially the same question
that Christina asked he asked basically
if you have let's think about it let's
just do a problem like that let's have
two cards and a spring in between them
and they're both on wheels okay how many
this is a planar motion problem
each of these bodies is capably in
planar motion have x and y and a
rotation but because it constraints how
many degrees of freedom does body 1 have
I hear one write its content allow it to
rotate it's got two wheels I don't allow
it to go off
because it's on on the ground I only
allow it to move in this direction same
thing to be said for this only one there
how many degrees of freedom do I have in
this problem I mean one for each mass
right so I have two degrees of freedom
how many generalized coordinates do I
need okay so my generalized coordinate
for this one will be x1 and for this one
will be some x2 okay if you are going to
do this problem by Lagrange
okay and let's see let's put a force now
to get back to your question let's put a
force here on one and we'll call it f1
all right and the potential energy
actually
now I don't want to do that
so the potential energy for this is some
1/2 K times the amount that you stretch
the springs right so you're going to the
amount that the difference between x1
and x2 minus the unstretched length so
x1 minus x2 minus the unstretched length
will call it l0
so this would be the stretch of the
springs if the spring had no length then
it would just be the difference in these
two positions right squared so my
potential energy can look something like
that
now we want to compute the general and
you know you could use Lagrangian you
could figure out two equations of motion
for this taking your derivatives so the
point of the question was about the
generalize
getting to the generalized forces right
so now the generalized force Q X 1 Delta
X 1 is f1 times the derivative of R 1
with respect to X 1 Delta X 1 so how
much does the position vector from
marking the position of this cart which
would be R 1 so R 1 is in effect X 1
right pretty trivial problem so the
derivative of R 1 respect to X 1 is just
1 and the amount that it then moves is
Delta X 1 so the virtual work done by
this force on that first cart is just Q
X 1 equals F 1 that's the generalized
force caused by this first mass on the
cart what's the generalized force QX 2
well it's some
f1 has a dot here this would be some X 2
with respect to X 2 Delta with respect
to X 1 Delta X 1 but how much does X 2
move when you cause a little virtual
deflection of okay the virtual work done
if I caused a little deflection of this
one is equal to the summation of the
forces that act through Delta X 2 now if
you move this a little Delta X 1 here we
figured out that that that this that QX
1 the generalized force 1 due to that is
indeed this but what's the generalized
force associated with motion Delta X 2
let's move this one now a little bit
when you move that a little bit how much
work does f1 do so we're getting we need
to get two equations of motion right and
you're going to get what you're going to
get 1 by taking derivatives with respect
to coordinate X 1 you're going to get an
equation of motion which so eom X 1
associated with x1 double dot here is
going to have on the right-hand side
some Q X 1 and we figured out what that
is that's just f1 and we're going to get
a second equation of motion associated
with x2 double dot the math celebration
of the mass of the second one and it's
going to be equal to some external
forces and there's other terms in here
right you have K X you have your K terms
and so forth in here but on the right
hand side or the external
non-conservative forces so are there any
conservative non conservative forces on
the 2nd mass none so what do you expect
q x2 to be okay so
to get back to your point when you're
computing the generalized forces its
back you freeze all of the movements
except one and figure out the work done
even though in the real system a force
will result in this whole system the
whole system will move to the right if
that's if I put a steady force f1 on
there the whole system will go off to
the right-hand side that would be the
solution to the equations of motion that
you end up with but for the purpose of
computing the generalized force on each
mass you only you fix the where the
masses are at some instant in time and
then one coordinate at a time caused a
little virtual deflection and figure out
how much work gets done so they see the
distinction between the solution to the
full equations of motion yes indeed
everything is going to move because of
that force and a little bit of work that
gets done due to the motion of just one
coordinate and then the other coordinate
with all through all of the
non-conservative forces that are applied
okay that did that get to your question
all right now and I'll set up I think I
have time to finish this
so last time you know we had this
problem this is this rod it's got a
sleeve and it's got a spring and we
figured out the potential and kinetic
energies and equations of motion this is
a planar motion problem at pivots dink
and slide up and down requires an
angular an angle theta and a deflection
X with respect to the rod and we figured
out T and V and we found the equations
of motion for it so here's my system at
Point a here spring sleeve theta
x1 y1
and the distance x1 was measured from
here to g2 the center of mass that's x1
this is in the F this is the direction
here this is the I 1 unit vector
Direction the coordinate system is my x1
and y1 so x1 is down the axis like that
so and we chose we this problem is a
planar motion problem there's two rigid
bodies the rod and the sleeve and we can
completely describe the motion of the
system with as two degrees of freedom
theta defines the position of the rod
and x1 defines the position of the
sleeve on the right so we have two
degrees of freedom and when we work this
out we end up with two equations of
motion and this was called M 1 M 2 this
was M 1 so one equation of motion was M
2 X 1 double dot
that was one equation of motion and I'm
just leaving out the general leave and
generalized force out of this for a
minute
we'll figure it out in the second
equation of motion this is the rod
so you get two equations of motion and
we worked it out in the last lecture and
we this week we can see this this
accounts for the mass moment of the rod
mass moment or of the sleeve with
respect to G so parallel axis theorem
adds a little more another piece to it
whole thing theta double dot and then
this is just due to gravity gravity
acting on the rod gravity acting on the
sleeve and on the right hand side you
need to get these QX you generalized
forces for generalized coordinate x1 and
generalized coordinate theta so we did
it in fact worked it out last time doing
the intuitive approach and what if we
were to try to do this then by the
kinematic approach that I described here
the force was applied here
it was horizontal we called it f2
because it was applied to mass 2
and in order to use this technique we
want now to compute qx1 we have a force
f2 and it is in a
right I want to do it
we'll have an inertial system
so we need to describe a vector in I
better not draw it out here so we'll
I'll just set this problem up and we'll
finish it next time I have a inertial
system Y and X so that in this system
this force would be f2 Capital J dotted
with the derivative of some vector that
runs here to this point and I'll call
that R to 0 so the derivative of R 2
with respect to X 1 Delta X 1 if you can
work this out and you you're done the
key to this is figuring out what is R 2
and doing it in unit vectors such that
you can complete this dot product so you
might so how would you describe what is
this position 2 here and what are its
unit vectors that break it down take
this R 2 and you express it in terms of
unit vectors in the inertial capital i
capital j system and once you've done
that you can take the derivative dot it
with that and you're done
so I will finish that next time you
might go off and think about it in your
notes from last time we already figured
this out we just did it the intuitive
way drew the F and figured out which
parts in the direction of x1 which parts
in the direction of Delta Theta and
we'll figured it out so you actually
already have the answer so go see if you
can do that ok